so what do you think is the role of
robotics in this high-tech uh
manufacturing
sort of like industrial robots robotic
arms all that kind of stuff um or even
even more complicated kind of robots
what do you think is the role of
robotics what do you think is the role
of ai in this manufacturing future
you're thinking about well robotics to
me is an extremely exciting field i
don't have the same expertise that you
do i have an adjacency but not the depth
of knowledge
um
have never really delved deeply into it
or made investments in it but i think
what's exciting about it is everything
from
doing jobs that are very dangerous for
humans
um enhancing the human experience
when you look at really repetitive labor
things that
you know
it might take away a job but is it a
good job for that that person is you
know spending 30 years doing something
highly repetitious is that
is that a good experience in life
so i think um and then when you think
about everything from military
applications
uh you know rescue we're already seeing
a bunch of those things and then
just lastly when you talk about that
human interaction with robots
when you start to have
the combination so you have some level
of intelligence and interaction
i mean
that's why
we always love the droids in star wars
right i mean it's uh
it it's it's exciting it captures the
imagination
um
and i i think look
many many hours and
have been spent on debating artificial
intelligence
and the the ramifications if things go
sideways and so forth
and i think those are all
you know those are
appropriate conversations to be having
ai is happening
i think it's actually happening slower
than most people realize
because there are tasks that humans do
every minute of every day
standing up without losing your sense of
balance i mean these are really hard
things
but i think uh there's enough
investment both in private industry as
well as nation states now on artificial
intelligence that it is coming
um so both in the software space in the
digital space
and in the physical space so we talked
about manufacturing so industrial
robotics
is very true that even in the factory
even the tasks that you think are
pretty uh
basic
you know the amount of small
intuitive decisions that humans make is
quite incredible so we have to be kind
of explicit about saying which tasks are
actually really hard
and humans are just really good at them
and
so
on and on the flip side in the digital
space with the social networks the
recommender systems with
all kinds of like uh personal assistants
in terms of voice
uh voice based ai systems all of that
there's
opportunities there to find niches where
ai can really have
a transformative effect
i think one of the
places that really haven't
this is where like you're worried to say
stupid things but i believe this very
much
that um
when we have ai systems in the home
currently you have somebody like alexa
and google home and so on
they're kind of
very basic servants
they tell you about the weather they can
play some music they can turn the lights
on and off all the kind of like smart
home stuff
i think there's a lot of value in
systems that
form relationships with us in the way
that pets do dogs
and cats
i don't know cats just for people who
have cats cats don't care about you they
they really don't they don't form any
kind of relationship i don't know why
you have relationship with them it's one
way anyway
sorry to throw some shade i'm just
kidding by the way that's a basic kind
of connection you have with another
living being uh then there's also just
friends you have different levels of
friends acquaintances you have lifelong
friends all that that that friendship
you have
i i really believe that there is some
aspect of the human experience
that um is deeply enriched by
interacting with other beings
and for um
systems computing systems artificial
intelligence systems in our world
to have the capability to engage in some
of that i think is not just an
opportunity to
to to uh help people grow become better
people but it's also just a good
business opportunity too and that hasn't
really been explored enough so that to
me is really
that's a whole exciting space that i
think will enable better industrial
industrial robotics it will it it will
empower a better facebook uh or a better
social network a competitor to facebook
that overthrows facebook so it'll it'll
create better technologies
that uh currently don't have that human
robot interaction touch so i don't know
that's super exciting to me but that
that has to deal with the mess
of
human nature
the the the reason that most robotics
people and ai people stay away from
humans
uh they stay away from the human robot
interaction problem is because humans
are complicated they're messy they're
hard to control
they're hard to uh
predict stuff about they're hard to make
sense of or like
test repeatedly because one human can be
drastically different from another human
and so for to deal with that is the
robotics problem is super hard
and so one of the questions
is uh
which problems can you remove the human
from consideration when you're trying to
solve the problem so like elon musk is
an example of somebody who believes
autonomous driving we can remove the
human from consideration we can solve
autonomous driving as a robotics problem
it's staying lane when there's a red
light you stop at a red light
you know if there is humans in the
picture like pedestrians
that's a ballistics problem it's just
treat them as a moving object
that has uh was with like 90 probability
keeps moving in the way they were in the
past few seconds with some smaller
probability that might stop or turn like
just do some basic models about them and
you'll be able to do it just fine so i i
tend to believe that
even driving
has to consider the full messiness of
humans the dance the game theoretic
dance of chicken that we all do
when
we jaywalk we look at the car is that
car that car doesn't that driver doesn't
have the guts to murder me so i'm going
to walk in front of and not look at the
car we do that kind of dance and ai
systems need to be able to play
um
uh do that kind of dance
you